hey 42 here have you ever wondered if
it's really as tough as everyone says it
is to get into Fort Knox and what makes
a place truly secure anyway
throughout history mankind has worked
with nature and its own ingenuity to
create some of the most fortified places
on the planet they can be found all over
the world and serve a wide range of
unique and interesting purposes that you
might not expect here are nine of the
most fortified places on earth when you
think of a place so secure you'll never
get in what's the first thing that comes
into your mind
well Fort Knox was probably the first
thing you thought of
that's because Fort Knox is synonymous
with a secure location in popular
culture surprisingly Fort Knox isn't
actually the name of the vault where the
goal is stored that's the United States
bullion depository Fort Knox is a 109
thousand acre Army Post which is home to
over 12,000 people the bullion vault
itself and even a high school the
grounds of the bullion depository are
secured 24 hours a day by an array of
CCTV cameras motion sensors and
minefields if you could get past all of
that you would still need to scale or
surrounding electric fences topped with
barbed wire get through the granite
walls and somehow open the 25 tonne
vault door the vault is guarded by the
United States Mint police an elite force
tasked with protecting assets belonging
to the United States Treasury under the
US Mint if that wasn't enough there are
around 30,000 army troops stationed at
Fort Knox Base so if you do decide to
try and take the title of the person
that stole from Fort Knox you better
bring an army because you'll be fighting
1 gold bars aren't the only treasures
that's have been stored behind the
reinforced door though in World War two
both the Declaration of Independence and
the Constitution were secured there for
protection morphine and opium were even
held there at one point in case the US
became isolated from raw sources of open
it seemed crazy that the government were
hoarding drugs in a gold vault but until
synthetic painkillers were invented
opiates were the only ones available I
guess they didn't like the idea of
fighting a war without painkillers
despite the legacy of Fort Knox it isn't
actually the largest depository of gold
in North America what we'll get to that
a bit later instead of gold bars
what about golden plates don't have any
of them laying around well fear not the
Mormon Church have got you covered
whilst not quite the golden pages of
Joseph Smith the microfilm reels and
sheets of microfiche stored in the
granite mountain records vault have
enough space on them to store over 4.5
billion pages of genealogical records
now that's what you call a family album
the vault itself is located one mile of
Little Cottonwood Canyon in Utah and is
built into the side of the mountain wide
loading bays allow access to the tunnels
leading into the rock face giving way to
rooms deep inside the mountain it's in
these deep secretive recesses that you
find them hundreds upon hundreds of rows
of cabinets containing an unimaginable
amount of family history all the rooms
are climate control to preserve the data
and each room is protected by heat and
motion sensors to detect any problems
that could lead to damage of the records
whilst it's not as guarded as Fort Knox
the measures which the Mormon Church
have gone through to protect and
preserve these records is simply amazing
they even have a lab on site ready to
save and reproduce any records that have
begun to degrade the facility and its
purpose are also relatively unknown to
most people the church has gone to great
lengths to keep the vault as secluded
unsecret eval possible sorry guys photos
of the site itself are extremely
difficult to find if you're ever
wondering where you came from and ever
use a genealogical database to trace
your ancestors there's a good chance
that documents stored in the Mormon
Church's vault played a part in tracing
your history somewhere in the deep
rolling hills of Pennsylvania there
lies an innocent winding road which
leads up to a remarkably out-of-place
chain-link fence if you keep going you
will eventually be stopped by some
serious looking security guards carrying
some equally serious looking weaponry
this is the point where you are either
going to be told to take a hike or
present your papers in order to enter
the highly secured facility on the other
side of the fence you've just found I in
mountain this is a place where most of
the vault owners are confidential so you
know there's going to be some serious
security in keeping things locked away
and hidden from prying eyes the facility
takes advantage of a retired limestone
mine and they effectively moved in after
the rocks moved out this provided a
geologically secure and cost-effective
way to house an incredibly valuable
storage bunker the 220 volts contain a
variety of valuables from birth
certificates to micro films backing up
some extremely valuable documents these
are the kinds of images that the world
couldn't do without such as the original
picture of Einstein sticking his tongue
out as you wander around the facility
probably with an escort you will notice
just how large it is the whole storage
area is around a hundred acres and
employs a team of a hundred and fifty
five people working underground to keep
its contents maintained deep within the
facility lies a room which emits a low
hum as you approach it no it isn't some
kind of doomsday machine hidden along
with the other secretive objects the low
hum comes from the energy efficient
generators and cooling ducts that keep
one of the world's most important data
hives running smoothly this is the home
of room 48 a data center used as a
backup for some of America's biggest
companies it isn't the only data center
humming away in the form of mine but one
of five room 48 is just a most well
known since it has some pretty clever
energy-saving tricks of its sleeve
giving it a 50 percent power advantage
over almost every other data center in
the country whether it's your family
photo stored in a vault or your cloud
storage business safe
backed up in room 48 your assets are
definitely going to be safe in Iron
Mountain one place that you'd probably
never want to go to even if you could is
the Korean DMZ or demilitarized zone
despite its name it's one of the most
heavily militarized areas on the planet
this no man's land stretches the entire
160 mile border between North and South
Korea and is 2.5 miles wide tall razor
wire fences which are usually
electrified line each side of the
no-man's-land listening-posts guard
towers and anti-tank barricades are
dotted across the landscape as far as
the eye can see
to top it all off there are hundreds of
thousands of active soldiers patrolling
both sides ready for war at any moment
if you do manage to evade the guards
scale the electric fences dodge the
landmines and avoid the automatic gun
turrets then you'll probably still end
up is the meal of some wild animal
due to the uninhabitable nature of the
dangerous no-man's land the area has
become something of a nature reserve
where some extremely rare plants and
animals have found their unlikely home
these endangered animals include the
iconic red crowned crane and the
majestic but dangerous Siberian tiger
the DMZ was created as an armistice
agreement to pacify the brutal Korean
War technically both nations are still
at war which is fairly unnerving since
North Korea has since developed nuclear
weapons and regularly threatens to use
them if provoked and that doesn't mean
everything has been peaceful between
1953 and 1999 around 500 South Koreans
50 US troops and 250 North Koreans have
died and sporadic outbreaks of conflict
within the highly militarized zone of
Knee around 50,000 people lots have
defected from the north to the South
only a handful have actually crossed the
southern border through the DMZ and that
goes to show just how fortified and
dangerous the border really is and how
well it worked
back in medieval times people used moats
and drawbridges to keep their annoying
neighbors away but one hobby took that
idea of a moat a bit too far
mon-sol michelle is a natural island
fortress the outcrop was formed 525
million years ago during the Cambrian
period and is made from volcanic Luca
grenades over millions of years - softer
rock around it was worn away to leave
them now 92 meter high outcrop towering
high above the surrounding Bay the abbey
is tidally isolated where it's high tide
the surrounding marshes lowlands and
languages are swallowed up into the
watery depths along with anything locked
outside the gates that could have been
peasants who weren't permitted to enter
or invading armies trying to claim them
on for themselves this natural process
provides a fantastic deterrent against a
siege since they usually lasted from
days to months but the tide meant any
army would only have a few hours to take
the fort or they would lose their men
supplies and siege equipment to the sea
even if you were determined enough to
swim up to the island to try and get
access you're probably better off
waiting for the tides and gates to lower
as mon-sol michelle has some pretty
serious fortifications the entirety of
the island is surrounded by a large wall
with battlements ready to repel invaders
the streets and passageways up to the
monastry are very narrow and are flanked
by elevated walkways that are perfect
for raining down arrows or boiling oil
basically if you are trying to get to
the top to check out the view but you're
not quite welcome you're gonna have a
bad time mon-sol michelle remained
unconquered young the entirety of the
hundred year war between France and
England even a small garrison fended off
a full attack by the English in 1433
several siege machines were abandoned by
the English during the failed assault at
a tides closed in and they can still be
seen today these days there's a bridge
which gives people access from the
mainland even at high tide but every 18
years or so a super tide comes along and
last year 2015 in March
temporarily submerged part of the bridge
making mon-sol Michelle a true island
fortress once more if you happen to find
yourself surviving a disaster that wipes
out most of the planet's crops there's
no need to worry about starving you just
have to take a quick trip down to your
local doomsday Seed Vault and pick up a
packet otter
this fall of our global Seed Vault is so
fortified that it could survive the
apocalypse or at least it should do or
else the owners might want their money
back the vault was designed to outlast
almost any imaginable disaster ranging
from extreme climate change to a nuclear
war built an annoying
Spitsbergen only 1,300 kilometers from
the North Pole the vault is about as
isolated as a location can be without
being inaccessible if you do manage to
fight your way through the local polar
bears and reach the vault you will find
a wedge-shaped hunk of concrete sticking
out of an icy Mountain get past the
heavy security and front doors and you
enter a reinforced tunnel which burrows
120 metres into the solid rock this fall
vard global Seed Vault serves as a
highly secure backup for other seed
vaults around the world that are in less
fortified locations the vault currently
holds millions of seeds from thousands
of crop species across the world secured
in airtight aluminium packets and
refrigerated at negative 18 degrees
Celsius whilst it's not the comfiest of
place you spend your time the conditions
are perfect for preserving most seed
species indefinitely because the
facility was built in such a remote
location with such frigid conditions
even if the power fails the temperature
would stabilize to around negative 3
degrees Celsius cold enough to keep some
crucial seeds preserved for decades it
may not be the most heavily guarded
location on the planet but a vault that
could potentially have lost the rest of
humanity definitely earns the right to
be on this list when a bunker used to be
the North American Aerospace command
center as well are spearheading US Space
Command missions you know that it's
going
have some pretty serious hardware behind
those heavy blasters buried 600 meters
under a granite Mountain in Colorado
Springs lies the Cheyenne Mountain
complex a massive military structure
built in 1967 by the US government to be
a central Operations base the book was
designed to withstand the most powerful
weapons ever created and is able to
survive a 30 Megaton nuclear detonation
within 2 kilometers a blast that would
completely flatten a large metropolis
like London or New York City that's
pretty impressive the main access tunnel
is lying with a series of 25-ton
blasters each with pressurized
compartments designed to filter out any
nuclear biological or chemical
contaminants at the height of its
operation these checkpoints would have
been heavily guarded and only those with
the highest military clearance were able
to enter the facility was fully
self-contained and provided living
quarters for round-the-clock operation
everything the base needed was provided
or stored on-site with power generators
food and water storage as well as fuel
reservoirs and shoring up the base could
still operate when cut off from the
outside world this level of secrecy and
security brought the base Fame in pop
culture with conspiracy theories and
television shows like Stargate being
based on the military complex the base
actually acknowledged this and installed
a seemingly high security door labeled
Stargate command which led to a storage
room for cleaning equipment Cheyenne
Mountain has since been retired from its
original command center duties and is
now reserved for training and commercial
communications use though fully
operational or not I would definitely
prefer to be standing inside the bunker
in an emergency than outside it banging
on the blast doors trying to get in I
mentioned earlier that Fort Knox wasn't
the world's leading stockpile of gold
and that's because that honor belongs to
the Federal Reserve Bank of New York is
the largest Federal Reserve Bank in
America and like the others it holds an
incredible amount of cash gold and offer
value
like most banks there is a 24/7 quick
response tactical Assault team on
standby for any sign that the bank is
being robbed the armed guards in and
around the building go through tough
training courses to spot the tell-tale
signs that give away someone who might
be there attempting to make a bigger
withdrawal than they're entitled past
all the security and down a few flights
of stairs lies the gold vault protected
by a massive steel door with a multiple
lock mechanism people aren't even
allowed inside the vault itself all
interaction and movement of gold is done
by robots carrying pellets
I guess robots are the only thing that
wouldn't get Gold Fever being surrounded
by tons of shiny yellow metal the vault
isn't just buried on the ground but dug
into the very bedrock of lower Manhattan
it actually sits at 80 feet below the
street level so if you plan on digging
your way in it's going to take a long
long time but that's assuming one of the
marksmen that patrol the perimeter of
the building doesn't spot you before you
even break through the concrete with the
armed guards security checks the heavy
vault doors and rock foundations I'm
afraid the only way you're going to see
any gold is if you of it the vault
contains 7,000 tons of gold as of the
last official inventory in 2011 that's
far more than reported anywhere else in
the world so if somebody does ever
manage the impossible and break into the
vault they're going to have a tough time
carrying it out when you picture a
heavily fortified location you probably
think about bunkers or vaults or even
your wallet when it's your turn to get
the next rounded but probably not bones
well this isn't any old boat the USS
George HW Bush is arguably the most
fortified military position on the
planet
despite well not actually staying in one
place it's one of 10 mimicked clutter
supercarriers in the United States Navy
and as well as being almost impervious
to attack it's one of the most
formidable sites for an enemy to say you
sure as hell don't want to be the reason
why it arrived our
and ready for action at 332 meters long
and weighing around 100,000 tons when
fully loaded it's no surprise that its
presence means business it's capable of
carrying 90 aircraft including
helicopters and can launch one every 20
seconds on offensive or defensive
missions capable of propelling entire
navies of some countries by itself a
u.s. Carrier Strike Group which worked
with the aircraft carrier has multiple
layers of state-of-the-art defense
dedicated cruisers destroyers and
frigates work together to defend the
carrier from attack by air and sea where
the assailants are other ships or
submarines the group worked closely with
advanced radar systems and electronic
countermeasures to spot enemies long
before they are in range and interfere
of their capability to fight the
aircraft carrier itself has an array of
weaponry from a number of surface-to-air
missile launchers that target enemy
aircraft to failings weapon systems
which lock onto incoming missiles and
shred them in a hail of bullets even if
something does make it all the way
through the battle group the swarms of
advanced aircraft and the carrier's
point defense guns you would still need
to get through the two and a half inch
thick Kevlar armor which protects the
vital parts of the ship so yeah unless
you have a large army with some
sophisticated weaponry you probably
aren't going to land a scratch there's a
fortified place for almost every
situation where it's surviving the end
of the world hoarding your treasure or
repelling the British thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2